THE JUNE SIXTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE. BEFORE PERCY LET'S
CALL ALL IN A STOP A QUORUM
MISTER CONSULTANT WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BERMAN
HERE. GALLAGHER CALDERON. LOW
MAYES YEAR MULLIN. WEBER WE
HAVE A QUORUM GREAT WE HAVE A
QUORUM DUE TO THE CURRENT STATE
HOME ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISK SINGER IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. ONLY ABLE.
THE NUMBER FOUR WATCHING FOR.
IN THE HEARING IN PERSON.
CONSISTENT WITH THE CUSTOM AND
PRACTICE OF THE HOUSE THE
PEOPLE PARTICIPATING COMMITTEE
HEARINGS MUST BE PROPERLY
ATTIRED WE ARE REQUIRING THAT
ALL THOSE ATTENDING THIS
HEARING IN PERSON WE'RE FACED
RIGHT WE HAVE A FEW TO INFORM
HIS TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUAL BIRTH YOUR ROOM FOR
THIRTY. CAPITAL HAVING A
PHYSICS PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN
PERSON HEARING IN THE SPACE WE
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE STUDENT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND THE
NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN ME. WE
CAN MAKE IN SIX. THE OFFICE
FOR. CALLS LEAVE SEVERAL FOR
THOSE HERE TODAY IN THE- WHY TO
TESTIFY ON THE BILL PLEASE-RAISE YOUR HAND IN THE MEMBER
WHO IS FOR THAT PRESIDING OVER
THE HEARING WILL ASK YOU TO THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I ASK. HUTCH THE
MICROPHONE THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU ARE DONE TESTIFYING OR
RETURN YOUR SEAT PLEASE BE SURE
TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITOL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME WE
WILL ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SIR THERE WHICH
ANYWAY SAVANNAH BIT. NUMBER
LET'S HEARING IS EIGHT. IN
SPEND. SIX NINE. TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE. NINE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN THE
DIFFERENT. DO YOU DO THAT. ONCE
AGAIN THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN
YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER
ON THE ASSEMBLY ACTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE WEBSITE
WELL AS ON YOUR TV OR COMPUTER
SCREEN AND I DO WANT TO DIE
JUST. NO WE'RE HAVING TECHNICAL
THESE UP WITH THE CALL IN
NUMBER EARLIER THIS MORNING WE
THINK IT'S BEEN RESOLVED SO IF
YOU HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO GET
THROUGH PLEASE TRY AGAIN NOW.
IS THAT RED. THE OPERATOR GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS HOW TO BE
BASED ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THE BILL IF YOU WERE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
THE NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVE STREAM GAS IN YOUR
SMART DEVICES. TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION PLEASE BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE IF YOU
THAT IF YOU ARE PRIMARY WITNESS
PROVIDING THE MONEY FOR AGAINST
THE BILL. YOU WILL FIVE LINE
AND WILL BE TO ME YOUR INTO
BILL YOUR CALL THEM SPEAK.
HAVING A PROBLEM WITH THE
MODERATOR PHONE. CALL THE- AT.
916-319-2094 AGAIN THAT'S.
916-319-2094 BY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP. I ALSO
KNOW THAT WE ARE ACCEPT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH SYSTEM THEIR
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT THANK YOU WITH AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHOD CAN YOU SERVE
THE APPOINT WALL ALSO MINDFUL
RESPECTFUL PUBLIC CERN'S WE ALL
FACE. WITH BOUNCE ONCE OUT OF A
WILL MOVE TO. THE THERE'S ONE
BILL ON THE AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY SINCE I
AM THE LEAD AUTHOR OF THAT BILL
I WILL HANDED THE GAVEL. NOT
REALLY. IT FIGURATIVELY AND
METAPHORICALLY AND ALL THAT
OVER DEVICE YOU'RE GALLAGHER TO
PROVIDE OVER THE PRESENTATION
OF THE BILL. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN- WE ARE ON
ITEM. NUMBER ONE WE ACTUALLY
HAVE ONE ITEM BEFORE US- IN
THIS HEARING AB EIGHT SIXTY. BY
GERMAN BERMAN AGAIN IT IS A-
IMPORTANT PRIORITY OF THIS
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC- HAS THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE INPUT. AND ACCESS IN
ALL THESE HEARINGS AND SO WE
HAVE PROVIDED. A EVEN THOUGH
PEOPLE OR THERE'S MORE LIMITED
PHYSICAL ATTENDANCE WE HAVE
PROVIDED A PUBLIC CALL IN
NUMBER FOR ALL THOSE WANTING TO
SPEAK. AND SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL SO PLEASE AGAIN
CALLING NOW- IF YOU. WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM AS A
REMINDER THE PUBLIC CALL AND
NUMBER. IS HEARING IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. STOCKS NOT TO.
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AGAIN THAT IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. CARE
BERMAN. GO AHEAD AND PRESENT
YOUR BILL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES. NO ONE
SHOULD HAVE TO RISK THEIR
HEALTH AND POSSIBLY THEIR LIFE
TO EXERCISE THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO VOTE
I'M SURE THAT'S SOMETHING WE
CAN ALL AGREE ON. AND YET
THAT'S THAT'S EGGS WE SAW ON
APRIL SEVENTH OF THIS YEAR WHEN
WISCONSINITES WERE FORCED TO
ELECTION. STANDING IN LONG
STANDING FOR HOURS IN LINES
THAT STRETCH FOR MILES. IN THE
MIDDLE OF A DEADLY HEALTH
PANDEMIC AMERICAN CITIZENS
YOUNG AND OLD. WERE DENIED THE
ABILITY TO VOTE BY MAIL THEY
WERE FORCED TO LEAVE THE SAFETY
OF THEIR HOMES TO VOTE IN
PERSON. DESPITE THE BEST
EFFORTS OF ELECTIONS OFFICIALS.
THOUSANDS OF VOTERS WHO
REQUESTED ABSENTEE BALLOTS DID
NOT RECEIVE THEM IN TIME TO
VOTE AND RETURN THE BY ELECTION
DAY. THEY WERE EFFECTIVELY
DISENFRANCHISED. IN THE
AFTERMATH WISCONSIN'S ELECTION.
IS BECOME CLEAR. THAT THE
HEALTH CONCERNS OF FORCING
PEOPLE INTO IN PERSON VOTING
DURING PANDEMIC FOR ALL TO READ.
AN ANALYSIS BY THE WISCONSIN
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES
FOUND AT LEAST SEVENTY ONE
PEOPLE. CONTRACTED COVERT
NINETEEN AFTER VOTING IN PERSON
OR WORKING AT THE POLLS AT THE
APRIL ELECTION. THIS IS WHY
I'VE INTRODUCED AB EIGHT SIXTY
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THAT EVERY
ACTIVE REGISTERED CALIFORNIA
VOTERS EMAIL THE BALLOT FOR
THIS NOVEMBER'S GENERAL
ELECTION. THIS WILL ENSURE THAT
EVERY CALIFORNIA VOTER HAS THE
ABILITY TO VOTE FROM THE SAFETY
OF THEIR OWN HOME. AB EIGHT
SIXTY WOULD NOT ELIMINATE
IMPROPER VOTING OPPORTUNITIES.
CALIFORNIANS WILL NEED SAFE IN
PERSON VOTING LOCATIONS THIS
NOVEMBER BECAUSE THEY NEVER
RECEIVED BALLOT LOST OR DAMAGED
THE BALLOT. NEED LANGUAGE
ERODING ASSISTANCE OR NEED TO
REGISTER TO VOTE. THAT'S WHY
THIS COMMITTEE WILL SOON
CONSIDER AS BEFORE TWENTY THREE
THE BILL I'M PROP JOINTLY- TO
ENSURE THAT SEAT. THE INPUT
OPTIONS AVAIL. AND ALL VOTERS
HAVE LIED ABOUT PRICE IN
PENDANT LIGHT. FINALLY AB EIGHT
SIXTY MAKES A NUMBER OF OTHER
IMPORTANT ACCOMMODATIONS TO
HELP FACILITATE THE EXPECTED
SURGE IN VOTING BY MAIL THAT
THIS NOVEMBER'S ELECTION. IT
ALLOWS COUNTIES TO BEGIN
PROCESSING RETURNED VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOTS EARLIER SO THAT
THEY CAN BETTER MANAGE THEIR
WORKLOADS AND GET MORE BALLOTS
COUNTED ON TONIGHT. THE END OF
THE DAY AND FOUR. BONTA BALLOTS
THAT THERE'S ARE NOT TO BRANCH
EYES BY ANY POTENTIAL POSTAL
SERVICE DELAYS. IT ALLOWS ALL
VOTERS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
FLEXIBILITY OFFERED BY REMOTE
ACCESSIBLE VOTE BY MAIL SYSTEMS
WHICH CAN BE ESPECIALLY
HELPFUL. FOR OWNERS WHO NEED
REPLACEMENT BALLOTS. OR WHO
WANT TO RECEIVE A BALLOT IN
THEIR PREFERRED LANGUAGE.
FINALLY A BEAT SIXTEEN STORES
THAT ALL CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE
THE ABILITY TO TRACK THEIR
BALLOTS AS THEY MOVE THROUGH
THE MAIL SYSTEM. AND ARE
PROCESSED BY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS. AB EIGHT SIXTY
SUPPORT OF ARM BY MORE THAN TWO
DOZEN DIFFERENT CALIFORNIA
ORGANIZATIONS. REPRESENTING
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE CONSERVATION VOTERS. AS
WELL AS BY SECRETARY OF STATE
ALEX PADILLA. ADDITIONALLY MORE
THAN FOUR THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS OF THE ORGANIZATION
SUPPORT AB EIGHT E. HAVE SIGNED
PETITION. PORT OF THE BILL. I
RECEIVE YEAH THAT THOSE FOUR
THOUSAND FIVE. NOT ALL IN IN
THE EARLY THIS MORNING. VOICE
SUPPORT FROM OTHER. THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR YOUR CAN AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TESTIFYING TODAY BY PHONE
IS ROBBIE AVALON FROM THE
OFFICE OF SECRETARY OF STATE
ALEX TO THE I THINK THAT IS A
GOOD CHOICE POINT MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THEY HAVE ALREADY
REGISTERED SUPPORT THEY HAVE A
SIGN IN THAT. POSITION SO THANK
YOU CHAIR I UNDERSTAND THAT WE
DO HAVE ONE PRIMARY WITNESS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TO MISTER
AVALON. IT'S GOING TO BE THREE
MINUTES TIME FOR EACH SIDE TO-
PRESENT ON THE BILL SO WE'LL
BEGIN WITH- MISTER AVALON WHO
IS AVAILABLE OVER THE PHONE I
BELIEVE. I AM HERE. MR AB ONE
GO AHEAD. OKAY GREAT THANK YOU
THAT YOU'RE BY CHAIR- AND
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FAMILY
MEMBER BERMAN AND YOUR STAFF
LEADERSHIP ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE- I AM ROBBIE AVALON HERE
ON BEHALF OF SECRETARY EIGHT
OUT TO BE A RECORD THAT STILL.
AB EIGHT ONE EVERY VOTER ENABLE.
THE BALLOT DURING A PANDEMIC IN
THE MATTER. THIS BILL DOES NOT
ELIMINATE IN PERSON VOTING AND
THAT OPTION WILL STILL BE
AVAILABLE IN NOVEMBER. THE
UPCOMING ELECTION ROUGHLY 87%
OF THE TWENTY POINT SIX SIX
MILLION REGISTERED VOTERS WILL
ALREADY BE RECEIVING A BALLOT
IN THE MAIL. AB EIGHT THAT YOU
PROVIDED THE REMAINING VOTERS
IN CALIFORNIA BILL BY MAIL
BALLOT I WILL ALLOW MORE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE THE
OPTION TO VOTE. ON THEIR OWN.
THE BILL ALLOWS THEM. DEVOTE
THEY BECOME KNOWN HOME FOR NOT
HAVING TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THE
RIGHT TO VOTE FOR THEIR HELP
OKAY. AB EIGHT SIXTY WILL
PRESERVE THE ART PIECE RIGHT
THE CAP THE BALLOT AND YOU SELL
IN THAT MANNER AND A SECRETARY
THE AUTHOR DIDN'T SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER AVALON AND I KNOW THAT-
WE HAVE- WITNESS I BELIEVE IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB EIGHT SIXTY.
ALL OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SORRY. I DO HAVE OTHER
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT SIXTY.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY AB EIGHTY
EIGHT SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DO HAVE COME FROM MINE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS THE CHAIR WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY.
PERFECT AND I WANT TO JUST
ADMONISH SO SHE JUST DID THAT
PERFECTLY. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR YOUR NAME POSITION
AND WHETHER YOU SUPPORT- AB
EIGHT SIXTY. SO CONTINUE PLEASE.
IN MINE ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
DIRECTOR WITH THE LEAGUE OF-WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND
NINE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING NO
WHATEVER MERRILL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION BETTER
AND STRONGER RECORDED EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHT. AND FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ERIN RODRIGUEZ TO THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. IN LINE
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
WITH THAT COMING OUT WITH A
THIRTY OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT SIXTY THANK YOU.
AND MINE ONE OH EIGHT. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ENTER BURROW ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. AND
NINE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. KATHLEEN
FOUGHT SANTEE CALIFORNIA AND I
AM STRONGLY OPPOSING. AND NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HAD A
QUESTION AND HAVE IT ON THE
DIRECTOR NAY FEATURED
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORT. IN MIND
ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR THIS IS
ERIC HARRIS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. IN LINE SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAROL ON BEHALF OF THE
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND PLUS
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
I AND ONE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS THE BRIDGE WATER MY
VOLUNTEER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT IN
STRONG SUPPORT. IN MINE NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS A
FIGHT ORDER REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA COMMON COPS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. IN MINE AT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK CRISTINA BOX HIM ON TEN
REPRESENTING YOU D. W. UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS WE REPRESENT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND I
HSS PROVIDERS WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT SIXTY. NINE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CYNTHIA
ROBERTS- ON FOR MATH VIDEO
CALIFORNIA I'M REPRESENTING
DISABLED VETERANS OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MINE ONE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE BASIC.
COMPONENTS IT'S STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT SIXTY. AND NINE ONE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANY OF THESE
YOUR INTERNET LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. IN EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AMY
HAMBLIN WITH NEXT GEN POLICY IN
STRONG SUPPORT
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD WORK WORRY OLD. WE'LL
CALIFORNIANS STRONGLY OF HOMES.
NINE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RUNNING THIS
IS KIM ALEXANDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA VOTER FOUNDATION ON
TOP. RIGHT THIRTY OUT ARE NEW
TRAUMA SPELL WHICH ISN'T THAT A
LETTER OF CONCERN I JUST WANT
TO SAY VERY QUICKLY THAT WE
APPRECIATE LEADERSHIP MORE
GENERALLY SUPPORT ABOUT THE
LEGISLATION WE ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT
VOEPEL AND- EIGHT WEBSITE AND
ITS LOOKUP TOOLS. OPERATOR
ROBUST MANNER THANK YOU IT
EXPANDED USE- FOR THE SECRETARY
TAKE TO PROVIDE SUPPORT AND
GUIDANCE TO THE COUNTIES FOR
EXPANDING ACCEPTABLE. ABOUT BUT
BY NOW AND I REQUIRE COUNTIES
TO PROVIDE EXTRA I'LL DROP OFF
LOCATIONS BUT ALL ACTION DAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
ALEXANDER- I DO. TO THE-
MODERATOR THE VOICE IN THIS GUY
THAT LEAVES OFTEN REFER YOU. I
KNOW OF BUT NOTICED A COUPLE
PEOPLE OF STATED OPPOSITION NOW
IS THE TIME FOR SUPPORT. OF
EIGHT SIXTY- THE OPPOSITION IS
NOTED- FOR THE COMMITTEE- BUT
JUST I DON'T KNOW IF. WE CAN
SURE THAT THIS RIGHT NOW IS FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE CALLING IN
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IN MY
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I KNOW
THIS IS A FORCE TO BE A SUPPORT
PLAYING BUT I AM IN OPPOSITION
ON THAT HAPPENED. AND. EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU- MADAME
MODERATOR AND- SO NOW WE WILL
GO TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
TO AB EIGHT SIXTY AND I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE ONE PRIMARY
WITNESS. AND OPPOSITION AGAIN
THREE MINUTES- FOR THE
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY AND- GO
AHEAD AND PROCEED- WHOEVER'S ON
THE LINE THERE FOR THE WITNESS
TESTIMONY. HELLO AM I ALIVE.
YES YOU ARE YOUR HEAD AND STATE
YOUR NAME AND I THINK THE
RECORD AND THEN GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED WITH YOUR OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
RUTH WIFE AND I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA. AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN SO WELL STATED
THE GOAL OF AB EIGHT SIXTY TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY CALIFORNIA
VOTER CAN CAST THE BALLOT. IN
NOVEMBER CONVENIENTLY AND
SAFELY WITHOUT FEAR OR THREAT
TO HEALTH AND LIFE. AND WHILE
HE AYE PCA DISAGREE BUT THE
PAST THAT AB EIGHT SIXTY TAKES
TO ACHIEVE THAT GOAL WE ARE
1100% SUPPORTIVE. OF THE GOAL
ITSELF. I REQUEST OF YOU TODAY.
IF YOU CONSIDER AND MITIGATE
THE UNINTENDED HEART THAT. OUT
OF MEN THE BILL WOULD BE DANDY
THE MAIN ABOUT TO. KNOWN
ADDRESS. OF ROUGHLY HALF IN THE
BUT- WHO HAVE BEEN CUT. OFF THE
RADAR FOR A MINIMUM OF TWELVE
YEARS AND MOST FOR DECADES
LONGER THAN THAT. TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND REGISTRANTS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY DUPLICATED ON THE
WORLD RECEIVED TWO OR MORE
BALLOTS. THE WEAVER BILLION
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO DO.
ALWAYS AND ACCEPTED MANAGEMENT
TO THIS BILL TO REQUIRED IN
ACCORDANCE WITH FEDERAL LAW THE
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND DO FOR
REGISTRATION. FIGHT BALLS. IT
HAPPENED. ACTIVE BE MAILED
RECKLESS NOTICE. AND MOVED TO
THE IMAC VOTER PRIOR TO THE
LEFT MAINTENANCE DEADLINE OF
EARLY AUGUST. FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THOSE LISTENING SO MAY NOT
BE AWARE MOVING VOTERS TO THE
INACTIVE LIST DOES NOT NAY GATE
THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE. IF THEY
RESPOND TO THE NOTIFICATION
THEY WILL BE RETURNED TO THE
ACTIVE WITH AN EMAIL THE
BALLOT. BUT SUCH AN ACT AND
WILL PUT PROTECT THE REIGNING
CALIFORNIA VOTERS FROM HAVING
THEIR VOTE THE VALUE BY THAT
AFTER THE WOULD HAVE ET AND
UNDETECTABLE ACCESS TO HAVE. WE
WOULD URGE THAT YOU INCLUDE THE
AND THEN EVERY. OF THE TWENTY
DAY GRACE PERIOD FOR BALLOT
ARRIVAL OR AT LEAST CONSIDER A
MORE REASONABLE AND DEFENSIVE
EXTENSION. THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
OF ANY COVERT IMPACT ON THE
EFFICIENCY OF THE US POSTAL
SERVICE. AND A TWENTY DAY
EXTENSION OF THE BALLOT
DEADLINE IS RIGHT. AND IT'S
COMPLETELY DEVOID OF COMMON
SENSE WELL IT DOES NOT
CONTRIBUTE IN ANY WAY TO THE
VOTERS ABILITY TO PROTECT
HEALTH AND LIFE WHILE VOTING IT
VERY DEFINITELY EXT IN A WAY.
AND THE- BALLOT IN THE
COLLECTION AND FRAUD. DO YOU
HAVE A IN EUROPE TODAY TO
RETAIN THE GOOD INTENT. BEHIND
AB EIGHT SIXTY WHILE REMOVING A
DEAL OF ITS DAMAGING IMPACT
ELECTION INTEGRITY. SELECT
INTEGRITY PROJECT CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
INCLUDE OUR PROPOSALS IN THE
FINAL VERSION OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THIS MORNING AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO. OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE PHONE LINES
ARE OPEN AND MADAME MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE. FOLKS ONLINE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO STATE THEIR
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT SIXTY.
YES AND AT THIS TIME IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. MY NUMBER FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS TERRY SMITH WITH THE
STATE OF JEFFERSON AND ALSO
WITH THE ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT TO CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU
BETTY. AN EIGHTY THREE YEAR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS- JAMES TAL THE
VETERAN EXPRESSING MY STRONG
OPPOSITION AB EIGHT SIXTY
ADDITIONALLY PLEASE INCLUDE THE
AMENDMENT THAT ASSIST TO LEASE
MENTIONED IN HER WHAT THE THING
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR. MY
NINETY NINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS RUNNING WATER I'M A
CONCERNED CITIZEN ACTUALLY I'M
VERY CONCERNED I AM. SUPPORT OF
MAIL IT AND BALANCE BUT THAT
THE PROBLEM IS JERRY DON'T
SERVE ON THE SIDE ARE
OPPOSITION YOU STATE YOUR
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IT'S NOT TIME FOR
TESTIMONY. HEY I HAVE A THREE
MINUTE NO YOU DON'T THE
ORIGINAL WITNESS HAD THREE
MINUTES AND EACH SIDE HAD THREE
MINUTES BUT THIS IS JUST
STATING OPPOSITION TO. THE BILL
NAME OF TITLE OF ORGANIZATION
AND OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT THAT DOESN'T REALLY SEEM
FAIR BUT I AM IN OPPOSITION
STRONG UP THE- THANK YOU. THEN
I'LL JUST CLARIFY FOR FOLKS ON
THE PHONE THIS THIS IS HOW WE
DO IT NORMALLY AND MAYBE PEOPLE
HAVEN'T SEEN HEARINGS EACH SIDE
HAS TIME FOR TESTIMONY AND EACH
SIDE DID GIVE TESTIMONY WITHIN
THE THREE MINUTES- AND THEN WE
GO TO OTHER PEOPLE AND
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION AND THEY
JUST STATE NAME TITLE- AND
WHETHER OR IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
TO THE BILL SO THAT THAT IS
PLACE. RIGHT NOW SO IF YOU
COULD JUST STATE NAME TITLE
AND- THAT YOU ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL THANK YOU. AND NINE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
ROBERT READ ON FOR SEEN THE
EAGLE OF A MEMBER OF THE
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT THE
CALIFORNIA AND AYE OPPOSED THE-
AB EIGHT SIXTY. AT NINE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT. I
HAD NINE EIGHTEEN. I'M OPPOSED
TO THE BILL MY NAME IS CAMILLE
CALLED FROM NEVADA COUNTY. BUT
I DO RECOMMEND- INCLUDING THE
AMENDMENT AS PROPOSED BY RUTH
WEISS WITH THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM. AND NINE SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND DALE VOTER-
INDIVIDUAL VOTER INTENDED-
COUNTY AYE OPPOSED TO BAIL BUT
SUPPORT- THAT AMENDMENT THAT
WAS BROUGHT FORWARD TODAY THANK
YOU. TEN NINE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EMILY CHANG YEAR SEVEN OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. AND NINE ONE OH FIVE
THE AIRLINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DRAG RACE WITH THE SALT
AND LIGHT COUNCIL AYE OPPOSED
TO BUILD BUT SUPPORT THE ADMIN
THANK YOU. AND NINE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS CHARLES CALM THE
SENATE OF THE BORDER. I PULLED
THE BELT BUT SUPPORT THE
AMENDMENT. AND NINE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BOB THIS CALLING BRITAIN
WITH CALIFORNIA LEADERS
NETWORK- WE NEED PLAIN VOTER
ROLLS OF ITS FOR NOVEMBER AND
WE SUPPORT THE AMENDMENT THAT
WAS PROPOSED BY RUTH WEISS BUT
OPPOSE THE BILL AS IT STANDS
THANK YOU. AND NINE FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ANDREA HEY SANDY
A GO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN. HELLO OKAY GOOD I OPPOSED
THE BILL AS WRITTEN BUT I
SUPPORT THE AMENDMENT. THANK
YOU MAN NINE ONE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS BETTY ROBINSON
I'M WITH THE WE THE PEOPLE
RISING I DEFINITELY UP CLOSE A.
B. EIGHT SIXTY BUTTON TO
SUPPORT THE AMENDMENT. AND NINE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
KAREN LAWLEY AND PLASTER COUNTY
I OPPOSE AB EIGHT SIXTY.
FOURTEEN AND THEN PUT OUT BY
THE ELECTION INTEGRITY PROGRAM.
CAN NINE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ARAMBULA ON ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA I'M OPPOSED.
TO EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY. TEN NINE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GEORGE OF
RIGHT THE SOLANO COUNTY
REPUBLICAN CENTRAL COMMITTEE
AND WE OPPOSE. AB EIGHT SIXTY
BUT DO SUPPORT THE AMENDMENT AT
TWICE- PUT IT PUT OUT. AND NINE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO. WHIMS
SELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT.
AYE OPPOSED. THE BILL BUT I
SUPPORT THEIR LIVES BY RUTH.
AND NINE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD RIGHT. HI
THIS IS PHYLLIS KERN COUNTY
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT- AND
THE POLL WORKER I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB EIGHT SIXTY BED TO
SUPPORT AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
IN NINE ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS IN YOUR AND CITIZEN
CALIFORNIA RESIDING IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AYE OPPOSED EIGHTY
EIGHT SIXTY. AND NINE ONE
THIRTY SEVEN. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND NINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS AN RANGERS FROM
OXNARD CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY IS STRONGLY
SUPPORT. A ROOF WIDE WITH THEM
AND NOT. AND NINE EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LYNN
HANDSOME OF A MEMBER OF THE
SOLANO COUNTY REPUBLICAN
CENTRAL COMMITTEE I WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS AMENDMENT A WE
NEED TO CLEAN UP VOTER ROLLS
BEFORE NOVEMBER. AND THAT HAD
TO BE DONE. THANK YOU. IN NINE
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SUSAN KENNEDY
SAN DIEGO COUNTY I OPPOSE THE
BILL AB EIGHT SIXTY AS IT
STANDS. CAN MIND TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD MY
NAME IS EDDIE BURN FROM VENDOR
ACCOUNTING I AM WITH THE
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT AND
AYE OPPOSED THE BILL AS IT
STANDS. AND NINE ONE TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS ON THE UP
SIDE IN VENTURA COUNTY WITH
ELECTION INTEGRITY THOUGHT YOU
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE AB EIGHT
SIX OUT AND SUPPORT THE
AMENDMENT. IN MIND- ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. NINE THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REALLY THIRTY THREE US
SERVICEMEN CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
STRONGLY PROS A. B. EIGHT SIXTY
ADDRESS. AND NINE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND
NINE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS DEB FLICKER I RESIDE IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THE ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECTS. ARE RECOMMENDED THE
AMENDMENT OTHERWISE I OPPOSE AB
EIGHT SIXTY AT THAT STAGE THANK
YOU. NINE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS DEBORAH FURTADO
CONCERNS THAT IT'S BEEN AND
VOTER FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY I
SUPPORT THE AN LX INTEGRITY
PROJECT. BUT AYE OPPOSED
WRONGLY BILL NUMBER EIGHTY
SIXTY WITHOUT THE RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENT THAT WAS PUT FORTH BY
THE WHITE. IN NINE THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NO MORE MOVE ON TO LINE SIXTY
ONE POINT SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS ONE BOB- WITH THE
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT OF
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SENATE BILL EIGHT SIXTY ISN'T
TORN ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT SIXTY
AS WRITTEN. UNLESS REPLACE-
MAINTENANCE ARE INCORPORATED
AND I WOULD SUPPORT IT. THANK.
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYBE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARK THE DOOR
IN THE NBA GO COUNTY I AM NOT
IN FAVOR OF THE- AB EIGHT
QUICKLY AS WRITTEN HIGHLY
RECOMMEND THE- PUT FORTH BY
RUTH WHY YOU FELT YOU ACTION
INTEGRITY. AND NINE FORTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS CHRIS FOSTER
FROM ORANGE COUNTY. I'M OPPOSED
TO AB EIGHT SIXTY BUT I DO
SUPPORT THE AMENDMENT PROPOSED
BY RUTH WHY. AND NINE ONE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANNE
HARRINGTON FROM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY I SUPPOSE A. B. EIGHT
SIXTY UNLESS AMENDED THAT THE
APPROACH. AND NINE ONE OH SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ARE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
BLIND OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
SEVENTY ONE. NINE SEVENTY ONE
YEAR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS THE NET HELLO FROM
VENTURA CALIFORNIA I AM A PART
OF A LECTURE IN INTEGRITY
PROJECT AND I HIGHLY- HOLD THIS
BILL AS GREAT. BRITAIN IF IT IS
NOT IN IT I COULD NOT SUPPORT
IN ANY WAY THANK YOU. IN LINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS LINDA
FROM THE CONSTRUCTION-
CALIFORNIA SERVICE MATT SPANISH
INTERPRETER AND NUMBER OF THE
SOLANO COUNTY REPUBLICANS I AM
OPPOSED TO THE BILL UNLESS YOU
THE AMENDMENTS ARE AT IT THANK
YOU. BEEN NINE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JANE BROWN LINK IN CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE THE BILL STRONGLY. TEN
NINE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS THE
NHL MEMBER OF FASTER COUNTY
REPUBLICAN I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
EIGHT SIXTY AND SUPPORT THE
AMENDMENT. NINE FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. QUITE
MYERS ROSEDALE PLASTER COUNTY I
OPPOSE A. B. EIGHT SIXTY BUT
WOOD SUPPORTED IF THE AMENDMENT
WAS ADDED THANK YOU. AND NINE
NINETEEN AIRLINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE MY
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WILL MOVE ON TO LINE ONE THIRTY
SIX. LINE ONE THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS PAUL RECTOR. HOME
FOR. NINE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD MY
NAME IS MARC JACOBS MY NAME IS
MARK J. THOUGHT AND I'M IN LOS
ANGELES AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB EIGHT SIXTY. TEN NINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND MOVING ON
TO LINE FIFTY NINE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE CHECK YOUR
MUTE BUTTON MIND FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND WE'LL MOVE ON
TO LINE NINETY NINE NINE NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THERE YOU HAVE IT
YES WE CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
UNDER THAT SO LONG YOU WITH THE
SIGN DIEGO SOUTH BAY
CONSERVATIVE I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE. NINE ONE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO LINE ONE
THIRTY TWO. ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS KATHLEEN AROSE
CO ON THE BALAKIREV'S XIN
INTEGRITY PROJECT I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB EIGHT SIXTY AND I DO-
SUPPORT GROUP WISE TO AMENDMENT
AND ALSO I THINK ALL OUR BALLOT
SHOULD BE IN ENGLISH THANK YOU.
NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
RICK CONSTRUCT AND INTER COUNTY
AND I OPPOSE AB EIGHT SIXTY.
AND NINE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PATRICIA WELL ONE CALORIE
COUNTING IT WOULD BE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB EIGHT SIXTY WITHOUT
THE AMENDMENT PROPOSED BY
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS JULIAN OR WELL
AS INVENTOR COUNTY AYE OPPOSED
THE BILL AS WRITTEN BUT SUPPORT
THE AMENDMENT. AND NINE ONE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORE FROM SAN
DIEGO COUNTY- AND REPRESENT
SENATE OKAY SUBWAY
CONSERVATIVES I'M AGAINST AB
ONE EIGHT SIXTY HAS WRITTEN BUT
SUPPORT THE AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED BY THE I. T. THANK
YOU. AND NINE FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHECK
YOUR MUTE BUTTON MINE FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WITH NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE. TO NINE
SEVENTY SEVEN ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS APRIL
CASE- DIRECTED OFFEND LOS
ANGELES CITY RESIDENT AND AYE
OPPOSED ABOUT THANK YOU. BEEN
NINE ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS BVERLY SADLER I LIVE
IN ORANGE COUNTY AYE OPPOSED
BILL AB EIGHT SIXTY. AND NINE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SEVENTY
SIX YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND HEARING NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE TO NINE
THIRTY EIGHT. ONE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ROBERT SADLER
FROM CITY BANK YOU BEACH I
OPPOSE THIS AMENDMENT. AND. AND
NINE ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS CINDY JOURNAL THAT'S YOUR
COUNTY THE I. T. AYE OPPOSED TO
A. B. EIGHT SIXTY. BUT APPROVED
SUPPORT THE AMENDMENT THANK YOU.
MINE ONE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS VALID APOLLO SAN DIEGO
COUNTY I OPPOSE A. B. EIGHT
SIXTY THANK YOU. LINE ONE FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS EUNICE
MALLORY I'M WITH THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT I LIVE IN
SOLANO COUNTY. STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL BUT SUPPORT THE
AMENDMENT PRESENTED BY ROUTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND NINE ONE
OH TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS DIANE
SUTTON FROM VENTURA COUNTY
MEMBER OF ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT THE CALIFORNIA. POSE AB
EIGHT SIXTY BUT SUPPORT
AMENDMENT PROPOSED BY RUTH
WEISS THANK YOU. AND NINE ONE
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I'M DALE
QUOTES ME WITH A REPUBLICAN
WOMEN FEDERATED AND ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT. AND ARE YOU
STRONGLY ABOUT ROSE THIS BILL-
BUT WOULD. MITIGATE IT WITH THE
AMENDMENT ONLY. AND NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
CARRELL I'M OF THE PLASTER
COUNTY AND I AM TOTALLY OPPOSED
TO A. B. EXACTLY UNLESS
PAYMENTS ARE ARE PUT THROUGH.
AND NINE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME- DAVID SCHECHTER
PRIDE THAT FIGURES IN VENTURA
COUNTY CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSED AB EIGHT SIXTY- AND
LEFT- AMENDMENT PROPOSED BY
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT OF
CALIFORNIANS INCORPORATED THANK
YOU. WE HEARD YOU SIR THANK YOU.
NINE ONE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS GLORIA MASSEY KEY NOW I
LIVE IN VENTURA COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHT SIXTY
WHAT ARE NOT THE AMENDMENT.
NHIáU AUTOPSY THEM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE WORK THAT YOU
DO. AND NINE ONE SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YES. VERY OLD SAN DIEGO
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
THE- THE BILL I DO SUPPORT THE
MOVES WISEMAN THANK YOU. IN
LINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS. ALSO LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY I'M AN E. I. T.
VOLUNTEER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
ANY FOR VOTE BY MAIL WHICH IS
AB EIGHT SIXTY BRIDGES UP UP AT
THE TOP AND THAT THEY WOULD
ONLY MAKE IT PALATABLE
THEREFORE I SUPPORT OF. AND ONE
MOMENT MY NINETY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS CONNIE SHARK AND I AM
AN ORANGE COUNTY REALTOR. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE OF THE BELL-
BUT I DO SUPPORT THE AMENDMENT
FROM OUR WORK TWICE. THANK YOU.
AND MINE SEVENTY TWO OR J. MADE
THE CARE OF THIS ERA PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS OPEN YES I
AM TOTALLY OPPOSED TO AB EIGHT.
I'M SORRY YOUR LINE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU WELL I'M
SORRY COULD YOU REPEAT YOUR
COMMENT PLEASE. YES I AM
COMPLETELY AND TOTALLY OPPOSED
TO A. B. EIGHT SIXTEEN WHEN I
DO COMPLETELY SUPPORT WITH WIFE
IT AMENDMENT. FROM THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT THANK YOU.
ONLINE ONE SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS. WATER HOLD A
MOBILE. INTERCOUNTY BUILDER I'M
OPPOSED TO THE BILL WITHOUT THE
MOMENT. AND NINE ONE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NOW WITH THE AP
CALIFORNIA VENTURA COUNTY- HOLD
A. B. EIGHT SIX SIX. AND ONE
MOMENT FOR OUR LAST COMMENT.
WELL I GUESS WE HAD TWO MORE
COMMENTS- LINE FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THIRTY NINE IS OPEN. BREAK
BUYERS SPENDING- COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSE. AND NINE ONE
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ABLE WITH
CALIFORNIA'S. AND I'M CALLING
TO A LOT OF MY STRENGTH AB
EIGHT SIXTY THANK YOU. AND NINE
ONE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
THE CHILDREN AND I AM A
REGISTERED VOTER IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. AND I IT'S ONLY BECAUSE
THE BILL BUT STRONG WITH THE
PLAN TO COMMONSENSE AMENDMENT
PROPOSED BY READ BY. TEN NINE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND NINE FIFTY
FIVE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE FIFTY FIVE YOU
MAY PROCEED. AND WE'LL MOVE ON
TO LINE ONE FIFTY FOUR. LINE
ONE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GOD AT
THE REGISTER VOTER PALMDALE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSED
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY. AND THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WE DO HAVE ONE MORE
LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUYERS BENDIGO COUNTY STRONGLY
OPPOSE. OKAY MODERATORS AT ALL
OF THE OPPOSITION. ACTUALLY WE
HAVE A FEW MORE CUED UP IF
WE'RE ABLE TO TAKE THEM. GO
HEAD YES PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU NINE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS THE LIGHT ROCK. BUT WE GOT
IT RIGHT. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
PLEASE. OKAY RETIRED BETTER I'M
IN EUROPE BRICK TO RETIRED
FEDERAL ON POINT SAN DIEGO NINE
STRONGLY OPPOSED AB EIGHT SIXTY
I BELIEVE IT PROMOTE VOTER
FRAUD AND SHOULD ONLY BE
WRITTEN IN ENGLISH. HEADLINE
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE SURE THAT
YOU GET FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY
AND I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED AB
EIGHT SIXTY. THANK YOU MA'AM.
AND NINE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THIRTY NINE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO YES YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY MONEY BREATH THE
COUNTY REPUBLICAN CENTRAL
COMMITTEE OUR OUR TEAMS ARE
CONSERVATIVE AND ALSO ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT CALIFORNIA
AND I'M- THOSE AB EIGHT. THANK
YOU MALABAR WITH THE FIGHT I'M-
IN MY NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NINETEEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY LET VERY
LAUGHTER COUNTY ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT I WORK WHEN
WHITE AMENDMENT ALL RIGHT POSE
THE BILL. IN NINE ONE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE ONE FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND WE'LL
MOVE ON TO LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE.
ONE ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I HAVE CLOSED EIGHTY
EIGHT SIXTY WITHOUT THE BILL
PROPOSED BY A GROUP WE WENT
WITH NATALIE HOPE I'M CALLING
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY
CALIFORNIA. NINE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE FIFTY YOUR OPEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. RIGHT BUYERS BENDIGO
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE. TEN
NINE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE ONE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE BILL YEAH YEAH OKAY. LINE
ONE SEVENTY YOU'VE MUTED YOUR
LINE AGAIN IF FIVE ALL ON ME TO
GET A LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES
ZERO CANARY HI THIS IS KAREN
HERE I'M CALLING FROM THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS- CHIRLA IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTY. THOSE SUPPORT. WE'RE NOT
POSITION BUT I BET THAT NOTED
THAT THAT WAS A SUPPORT OKAY.
AND THAT WAS THE LAST COMMENT
IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OUR THIRD
CATEGORY TWEENER SO I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE.
TWEENER ON THE LINE THERE IS A
SO. IF YOU'RE A TWEETER GO
AHEAD NOW IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
THE STATE YOUR- POSITION. ALL
RIGHT AND WE DO HAVE LINE
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS KIM
ALEXANDER IREADY SHARED MY
COMMENTS EARLIER THANK YOU SO
MUCH THE CALIFORNIA VOTER
FOUNDATION. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
THAN WE ANY OTHER TRAINERS. WE
DID HAVE TO MORE CUED UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE YOU'RE NEITHER
HOT NOR COLD WE HAVE MY- WHERE
PLAN ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING I AM TRICIA
WEBER LEGISLATIVE CO CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COURTS IN ELECTION OFFICIALS
ARE COMMITTEE IS OFFICIALLY
NEUTRAL ON AB EIGHT SIXTY
BECAUSE OF OUR PROCESS ALLOWING
FOR ANY COUNTY TO PARTICIPATE
ON ANY PARTICULAR DAY. IT MAKES
IT A LITTLE MORE DIFFICULT
ESPECIALLY WHEN MATTERS OF OUR
IMPORTANCE LIKE EIGHTY EIGHT
SIXTY. HAVING SAID THAT OF THE
MEMBERS WHO PARTICIPATED AT THE
LAST MEETING THERE WAS NEAR
UNIVERSAL SUPPORT FOR THE IDEA
OF SPENDING ALL ACTIVE
REGISTERED VOTERS A VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOT. AT THE WAY
PROVIDING SAFE WITH TO VOTE
DURING THE ANTICIPATED SECOND
WAVE OF THE VIRUS. NOT ALL THE
IDEA OF X. THE USE OF OUR AB
BM. AND APPRECIATE THE
EXPANSION OF PRACTICING BALLOTS
TO BEGIN AT TWENTY NINE DAY. WE
APPRECIATE BEING ABLE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR THIS
LEGISLATION IS BEING CRAFTED
NOW TO SPECIALLY LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR REVISITING OUR
CONCERNS REGARDING THE POSTMARK
DATE. MANDATE THAT MEET
STATUTORY DEADLINE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND ONE ONE ONE FIVE
NINE IT. YES WE DO HAVE OF
ACTUALLY FOR MORE IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME- LINE ONE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
MERRY PLAN HELLO CAN. AND I
WILL TRY VALLEY REPUBLICANS
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO AB EIGHT SIXTY.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MORNING MY NAME IS
DAVID THE TELL I'M AN
INDEPENDENT CITIZENS FROM
OXNARD CALIFORNIA AYE OPPOSED
A. B. EIGHT SIXTEEN BUT IT DID
MUCH FASTER I. STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE IMMENSE- RECOMMENDED BY A
BLUE WHITE. THANK OKAY THANK
YOU AND WE ARE. WE'VE ALREADY
PASSED OPPOSITE IN SUPPORT. SO
ANY OTHER INBETWEENERS. LINE
ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD HI THIS IS
CALLING FLORIAN I'VE BEEN ON
THE LINE FOR QUITE AWHILE AND
THE NUMBER WAS GIVEN BUT YOU
DIDN'T CALL IT SO I AM A PO. AB
EIGHT SIX. FORTY MM BUT I'M
FROM CAMARILLO CALIFORNIA. HE
HE I THE I. P. A. COUNTY THANK
THANK YOU MA'AM YOU'RE YOU'RE
OPPOSITION WAS REGISTERED WITH
THIS COMMITTEE. AND NINE ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HOPE YOU GET
ME. YES GO AHEAD PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU MY NAME IS
CARLA NOTHING ONE OF COUNTY I'M
A MEMBER OF THE TECHNICAL ONE
OF FITNESS TAX WATCH GROUP. AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
MODERATOR WE ONCE AGAIN AT THE-
I'M SORRY IF WE CAN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK. YES THERE
ARE OF NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
QUEUE FOR TRAINERS OKAY. I WILL
WE WILL NOW MOVE. HAVING HEARD
ALL CATEGORIES BOTH SUPPORT
OPPOSE AND INBETWEENERS SO
WE'LL COME BACK NOW TO
COMMITTEE AND I'VE I KNOW AT
FIRST I WANTED TO JUST GO TO
BACK TO THE CHAIRMAN AND GIVEN
THE OPTION I KNOW ONE OF THE- A
LOT OF. OPPOSITION TO. NEAR IN
PEOPLE BRINGING UP THE ISSUE OF
AN ACTIVE VOTERS AND I KNOW YOU
DID TAKE AMENDMENTS- ADDRESSING
THAT ISSUE SO MAYBE I JUST GIVE
YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THAT. PART OF THE OPPOSITION.
THAT SURVEYS OR NOT IS IT WHAT
I THINK EVERYBODY WHO WHO
CALLED TO WEAR WHETHER YOU ARE
A POOR WHETHER YOU OPPOSE YOU
RICH WIENER. YOU KNOW IT'S A
BEAUTIFUL THING WHAT WE'VE ON.
BECAUSE OF THE COVENANT IN
PANDEMIC WE HAVE. BROUGHT IT
BARKER SEE AND- PEOPLE DEBATE
THE- OF THE CALL THIS. NO
EXPAND IN LAW. FAVORITE YOUR
HEALTH. YOUR VOICE HEARD IT YOU
ABLE TO CALL IN AND HAVE YOUR
VOICE. FROM THE SAFETY OF YOUR
OWN HOME- AND I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
THIS BILL. IS TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE THEIR
VOICE HEARD FROM THE SAFETY OF
THEIR OWN HOME WALL WORK SIR
CURRENTLY STRUGGLING ON A- A
WORLDWIDE HEALTH PANDEMIC.
MISTER VICE YOUR BRIDGES IN ON
AN ACTIVE VOTERS- I'VE HAD. YET
WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO PROPOSED
BECAUSE- I THINK THAT THE WHOLE
SENSE BY. ENACT BOATERS. LEFT
TOUR OF. THEY WANT ALL TO SEND
BALLOTS TO AN ACTIVE THE REAR
IS THAT THE BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE IN THE LAW AROUND WHAT
THE STATE DOES IN TERMS OF AN
ACTIVE VOTERS OF THE LANGUAGE
IN THIS BILL IS MODELED AFTER
LANGUAGE IN THE VOTERS CHOICE
ACT AND IN EXISTING LAW
GOVERNING MAIL BALLOT ELECTIONS
AND ALL MAIL BALLOT PRECINCTS
THE LANGUAGE IS NEVER BEEN
INTERPRETED TO REQUIRE MAILING
BALLOTS TO AN ACTIVE VOTERS FOR
THE MORE. SECTION TWENTY TWO
TWENTY SIX A TWO OF THE
ELECTIONS CHO CLEARLY PROVIDES
THAT VOTERS WITH AN INACTIVE
VOTER REGISTRATION STATUS DO
CIVIL ACTION MATERIALS- AND
THERE ISN'T ANY CONFUSION THAT
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS ARE
ELECTION MATERIALS. FINALLY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS POINT IS
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR I AMENDED THE
BILL. TO ADULT LANGUAGE
SPECIFYING THAT NOTHING IN THE
BILL SHALL BE CONSTRUED TO MEAN
THAT A VOTER WITHIN AND VOTER.
IS WORSE EVIL BY MAIL. TWENTY
FOUR. STATE WHY GENERAL SO I
THINK IT'S SAFE TO SAY WE PUT
THAT. ISSUE TO BED THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIR. OKAY. NOW GO
TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON AB
EIGHT SIXTY S. SENATE MEMBER
LOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DIDN'T
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION AND
THE RECOGNITION THAT DEMOCRACY
RECOGNIZES THE FULL VARIETY OF
OPINION AND YET THAT IS. OF
ILLUSTRATIVE OF WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY TO
ENSURE THAT IT WHEN FORCES IS
HEARD ESPECIALLY DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AND HOW DO WE FUNCTION
AND ALLOW FOR THOSE VOICES TO
BE RECOGNIZED IN HER. AND DO
YOU HAVE DEMONSTRATED- AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE
CONVERSATION THAT YOU KNOW I'VE
HAD BUT ALSO IN THIS COMMITTEE
TO HELP ENCOURAGE AND TO
INCREASE ACCESS VERSUS THAT OF
LOWERING BARRIERS AND IN FACT
IT IT IS ALSO POINT TO KNOW
THAT YOU UNDERSTAND INTRODUCED
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION BACK
IN APRIL. TWO WHICH
SUBSEQUENTLY THE GOVERNOR
ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER AND
THIS HELPS TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE A DEMOCRATIC PROCESS TO
ENSURE THAT AT IT BECAUSE HAVE
DEBATE HAVE CONVERSATION AND
THAT THERE IS- A FULL ANALYSIS
OF THE PROS AND CONS SO SHOULD
THAT TOO BUT I THANK YOU FOR
CLEAR VOICE ON THIS TOO BECAUSE
I KNOW THERE WAS TING TO. AND
CAN EXPECT NUMBER EXECUTIVE.
AND WHAT ABOUT THE AUTUMN MUST
CONST NOW FOR THE LAW TERM BUT
AGAIN- THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
DOING SO AND WITH THAT ALSO-
MAKE A MOTION IN SUPPORT. I HAD
MOVED TO A MEMBER LOW AND
SECONDED BY ASSUME RECALLED
ROOM. OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
YES IS A MEMBER MASON I JUST
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
FOR BRINGING THIS. FORWARD
THERE HAS BEEN- CONVERSATION OF
THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS AS WE'VE
BEEN BACK IN SESSION ONE IN
REGARDS TO- THE- ADMINISTRATION
AND HIS USE OF EXECUTIVE
ORDERS- I'VE BEEN A CRITICAL-
OF THE- THE FEDERAL CHIEF
EXECUTIVE. AND THE NUMBER OF EX
EXACT- IS THAT HE IS ISSUED-
I'VE ALSO BEEN CRITICAL OF THE
OF THE ORDERS ARE GOVERNOR. I'M
HAS PUT IN MOTION I- THEM
SOMEBODY THAT BELIEVES THAT WE
MUST LIKE THE LA SAID MY GEL.
GUARD CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE IN
THIS LOCKER SEE. THE LEAD I AM
A GOING TO SUPPORT THIS SUPPORT
THIS TODAY I'M A STRONG
PROPONENT OF THE VOTE BY MAIL I
THINK IN FACT I'VE BEEN DOING
IT BUT VIRTUALLY MY ENTIRE
ADULT LIFE I DON'T KNOW WHY OR
THE LAST- A EW MONTHS- ALL OF
A SUDDEN IS THERE'S THIS
QUESTION THAT'S BEEN POPPING UP
ABOUT WHETHER. IT'S FRAUDULENT
I FIND IT INTERESTING THAT
PEOPLE WHO VOTE BY MAIL OR THE
ONES THAT ARE SAYING THAT IT'S
IT IT'S FRAUDULENT SO I'M I'M
DEEPLY CONCERNED CONCERNED
ABOUT JUST THE MESSAGE IN THE
RHETORIC OF THAT IS HAS GOTTEN
OUT THERE I DO. ACTIONS ARE OUR
SOUND- ARE THERE OF ONE OFFS
HERE THERE TOWARD THE BAR I'M
WE HAVE A FANTASTIC THE
PROGRAM- NOT JUST IN THE STATE
BUT IN THIS THIS COUNTRY AND TO
THE VOTERS OF THE STATE CAN CAN
NO OF THAT I WENT UP WHEN THE
WHEN THE POLLS ARE COUNTY WITH
ABOUT COUNTED AT THE DATE THE-
THERE IS A OUR FOUND. QUESTIONS.
OKAY THE SO MISTER CHAIRMAN I
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BO.
TAKING ON THIS ISSUE BUT ALSO
REALLY TRYING TO LISTEN AND GET
ALL THE INPUT- YOU KNOW AS WAS
MENTIONED- NO WE DID HAVE THIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER YOU KNOW YOUR-
LEGISLATION I THINK TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT MANY OTHER THINGS THAT
THAT NEEDED TO BE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT- FOR INSTANCE I KNOW.
YOU KNOW IN THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
SAID EVERYONE WOULD HAVE TO USE
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
TRACKING SYSTEM. YOUR
LEGISLATION MAKES CLEAR BECAUSE
SOME COUNTIES HAVE THEIR OWN
TRACKING SYSTEMS. ALLOWS THOSE
COUNTIES TO USE THOSE OF THEIR-
YOU KNOW IN THE BACK OF A
BETTER QUALITY- THAN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S- TRACKING
SYSTEM- YOU ALSO DID DEAL WITH
THE ENACTED VOTER ISSUE WHICH I
KNOW THAT. WAS SOMETHING THAT
WAS A CONCERN THAT YOU KNOW
PEOPLE WHO ARE INACTIVE WOULD
NOT BE GETTING- BALLOTS- SO. I
DO APPRECIATE THE COOPER AND
ARE YOU APPROACH THIS. I ALSO
AGREE I THINK THAT. THE MALE
BOWING OUT MAIL IN BALLOT-
ELECTIONS ARE SECURE- AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN- IN THE IDEAL
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE SOMEONE IS.
TURNING THEIR MAIL ABOUT THEY
FILL THAT OUT THEY PUT A MALE
THAT AS A SECURE. WAY OF
LOGGING. A BOAT. WHERE THEY SIR
INCOMES IT MORE THAT. QUESTION
IS REALLY A THE ISSUE OF. A
BALLOT HARVESTING- IF YOU WILL
AND THAT PEOPLE MIGHT BE
GETTING BALLOTS THAT. YES
SOMEONE TAKING FROM SOMEONE HEY
JUST SIGNED ABOUT AND I'LL FILL
IT OUT FOR YOU THOSE ARE THINGS
HARD TO PROVE. OTHER THINGS
THEY'RE REALLY HARD TO FIND-
BUT- YOU KNOW THERE'S CERTAINLY
BEEN A LOT OF CONCERNS THAT
THAT MIGHT BE HAPPENING- AND
ALSO IN A COVERT NINETEEN WORLD.
ONE OF MY CONCERNS IS BEEN THE
HALF OF IT YOU KNOW WE'VE
ALLOWED FOR ABOUT HARVESTING OF
LOT FOR PEOPLE TO GO DOOR TO
DOOR LITERALLY. GETTING BALLOTS
IS THAT REALLY THE BEST
PRACTICE IN THIS NOVEMBER
ELECTION. TO ALLOW THAT TO
CONTINUE. I PERSONALLY THINK
THAT WE SHOULD. SCALE THAT BACK
CONSIDERING THE CIRCUMSTANCES
WERE AND ALL THIS IS REALLY
FOCUSED ON THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION AND SOCIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES AND SO THAT THAT THAT
IS ONE CONCERN AYE. AS WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE. AND THEN AS
AS WE'VE DISCUSSED I CERTAINLY
WANT ANYBODY WHO IS WHO HAS
MADE A VOTE IN TURN IN A
BALLOT- HONOR BEFORE ELECTION
DAY FOR THAT BOTH TO BE COUNTED.
YOU DID IN YOUR LEGISLATION
PROVIDE FOR A WAY TO
AUTHENTICATE BALLOTS THAT COME
AND THEY HAVE TO HAVE THE
POSTMARK. FOR INSTANCE THAT'S
ONE WAY TO AUTHENTICATE- BUT
WERE ALLOWING UP TO SEVENTEEN
DAYS FOR ABOUT TO COME IN AND
SOME OF THOSE DOUBTS MIGHT NOT
HAVE A POSTMARK. YOU KNOW THERE
IS SOME QUESTION ABOUT OKAY ARE
THOSE COULD THOSE POTENTIALLY
BE BALLOTS THAT ARE TURNED AND
MAYBE THEY'RE FOUND AFTER THE
ELECTION AND TURNED IN.
SOMEWHERE THERE IS TURN ABOUT
ISSUES THERE AND SO- YOU KNOW.
THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT I
THINK WE- I THINK WE CAN DO
THIS THIS DOES HELP PROVIDE FOR
A SAY PROCESS BUT THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT I.
THAT I KIND OF STILL HAVE BEEN
MAYBE I'LL JUST GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JUST ADDRESS.
THOSE ISSUES. AND AGAIN I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR. WHAT I THINK.
YOU HAVE DONE IN TERMS OF
TAKING THIS ISSUE ON AND REALLY
GETTING. A LOT OF THE INPUT TO
MAKE SURE THIS IS BOTH A SAFE.
AND THAT WE ENSURE THAT THERE'S
PROPER PROTECTIONS. OF THE VOTE
BUT I'LL JUST GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. SURE APPRECIATE THE
MOST PRESSURE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE MULTIPLE CONVERSATIONS THAT
YOU AND I HAVE HAD IT YOU KNOW
JUST ABOUT THESE ISSUES. YOU
KNOW GIVEN THAT WE'RE ASKING
PEOPLE TO STAY HOME TO AVOID
THE SPREAD OF THE CROWN OF OURS
I THINK THE LAST THING. THAT
WOULD WANT TO DO IS TO TELL A
VOTER THAT THEY CAN'T ASK
SOMEONE THAT THEY TRUST. TO
RETURN THERE. I AND INSTEAD
FORCE THE VOTER LEAVE HOME TO.
THEIR BALLOT IF ONE VOTE IN THE
NOVEMBER ELECTION. AND WHILE
MANY VOTERS HAVE THE OPTION ON
THE BACK ON NOT. VOTERS HAVE
HOME MAIL. OF FOR THE MORE
PUTTING ABOUT IT IN THE
MAILBOX. ELECTION DAY RISKS THE
BALLOT NOT BEING COUNTED IF THE
MAILBOXES ARE. IT'S LAST OF THE
DAY. AND I JUST WANT TO. YOU
KNOW YOU YOU. TO SOMEBODY
GIVING THEIR BALLOT TO SIGN A
BALLOT GIVING IT TO SOMEBODY
ELSE TO FILL OUT THAT'S A- ON
THE- THAT IS. GOING CAL OF. NOT
THAT ARE THE HAVE SEVEN ON A
DID HAVE IT SURE WE HAVE NO
HAVE THAT IT IS HOW BUT BUT YOU
KNOW THAT THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT IF IT DOES
HAPPEN IS ALREADY VERY VERY
ILLEGAL- AND IT IS A FELONY.
THERE WAS A FELLA THERE'S ONE
OTHER ISSUE THAT YOU MENTIONED
THAT I WANTED TO ADDRESS- BUT
YEAH THE ISSUE OF ALLOWING
DOLLAR RIDE UP TO SEVENTEEN
DAYS AFTER THE ELECTION TO BE
COUNTED. NOT WITH SOME OF THOSE
BROUGHT TO US BY. A SUPPORTED
AT LEAST BY. YEAH CAL. SO OF
CLERKS AND ALLOW. IF EXPRESSLY
ADVOCATED FOR THIS. OR A
SIMILAR PROVISION- THEMSELVES
AT THE CONCLUSION OF WORKING
GROUP DISCUSSIONS THAT. THE
SECRETARY OF STATE HAD CONVENE-
AND IT'S REALLY JUST AN
INSURANCE BACKSTOPS. BECAUSE IN
THE MIDDLE OF JUNE WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE SITUATION IS
GOING TO BE LIKE. IN NOVEMBER
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT.
INTERNATIONAL ALL IS GONNA BE
LIKE SO I THINK IN THE BILL
THERE'S ENOUGH PROTECTIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT IF A BALLOT DOES
HAPPEN TO ARRIVE- YOU KNOW
FOURTEEN DAYS FIFTEEN DAYS
SIXTY DAYS SEVENTEEN DAYS AFTER
THE ELECTION. STRONG SECURITY
MAKING SURE IT. THAT'S BECAUSE
OF THE FAULT OF THE POSTAL
SERVICE OR SOMETHING IN THE
MAIL STREAM IT'S NOT THE FULL
OF THE VOTER. AND I THINK THAT
WE SHOULD DO EVERYTHING THAT WE
CAN TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
VOTERS VOICES HER- SO THAT'S
ALL THAT'S TRYING TO ADDRESS
AND AGAIN IT YOU KNOW IF I
VOTER WORK TO LINE- AND- ON THE
BALLOT. OR ON THEIR OWN THE
BILL BY MAIL ENVELOPE. THAT IS
DIFFERENT THAT'S A FELONY- AND
WE HAVE STRONG LEGAL
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE TO MAKE
SURE THAT. YOU KNOW IF THOSE
PEOPLE- ARE FOUND TO HAVE LIED
AND POST DATED THEIR THEIR
BALLOTS. THEY'LL THEY'LL BE
PROSECUTED FOR THAT SO. I THINK
THE- I WOULD WOULD TRY TO
STRIKE- I KIND OF YOU KNOW
MIDDLE ROAD IN TERMS OF.
ALLOWING THESE PROTECTIONS JUST
TO TRY TO ANTICIPATE. ALL THE
THINGS THAT MIGHT HAPPEN IN
NOVEMBER- YEAH THAT THE KIND OF
WORST CASE SCENARIOS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE PROTECT VOTER
CALIFORNIA AND THEIR ABILITY TO
VOTE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- ANYTHING
FURTHER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE- IS THAT YEAH I THINK
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH IT- REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL CONVERSATIONS
FOLKS HAVE HAD- AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
HOLD THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND I
AND AS THAT LAST PART AND THE
CHECKS THAT YOU DID PUT INTO
THIS BILL. ON THAT I AM GOING
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY-
BASED ON THIS BEING A- YOU KNOW
FOCUSED ON THE SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE HAVE IN
THIS NOVEMBER ELECTION. AND THE
OTHER CHECKS AND THAT YOU'VE
PUT INTO THIS BILL I THINK IT
IT MAKES THAT RIGHT BALLOT SO
THERE WILL BE A POINT TODAY
AND- MR CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO RETURN
THE BILL TO THE FLOOR WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT SENATE
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
BERMAN HI BERMAN I GALLAGHER
AYE. GALLAGHER AYE CALDERON.
ALL THEIR OWN I LOW. LOW I
MAYES MAYES AYE MULLIN MULLIN I
WEBER. AND IT'S SIX ZERO. OKAY
THAT SIX ZERO AND THAT BILLS
OUT THING ON A REGULAR LEAVE
THE- TO HAVE OTHERS COMING THAT
HONOR NOT SURE OF DOCTOR OVER
MISSION SHOULD SHE MEANT UP TO
GET BY ELEVEN FOR FIVE SO MAYBE
WE'LL GIVE IT AND IT'S FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR HER TO COME%
DOWN AND IF IT DOESN'T WORK OUT
THEN YEAH WELL I'M FINE FINE TO
DO THAT. LEAVE IT OPEN- AND FOR
OTHERS DATA. BEFORE WE ADJOURN.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SIR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BRIDGET.
I'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
BUT
DIFFICULT. BACK HERE WITH- THEY
CAN COME BACK HERE WITH YOU I'M
GONNA TRY TO CHECK WITH YOU CAN
AND SEE IF YOU CAN HEAR. UP
WITH OUR OFFICE WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE GOING BACK. FOR THE.
WORKING AROUND THE- BASED ON
THE ONE. WELL MAYBE NOT NORMAN
MAYBE ANOTHER. HELLO THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR AND
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT ARE LOST
MANY MEMBERS CAN BE ABLE TO
MAKE IT BACK FOR QUITE AWHILE
SO WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
THAT A DURING THE HEARING
THANKS EVERYBODY. THANK.